is different than the kind of acts of
imagination that go with fiction because
history actually happened
we rode in
on a horse that we didn't create
we ought to know something about that
horse and the horses before it and
before we aim for it well come on what
are we waiting for if we look at the
times we're living in the
the graph goes
graph goes boom like this in terms of
every measure of material prosperity
longevity health etc
but we don't know that if we don't know
what things were like before
and to make it count there's a tendency
to think we can
decide questions of principle by
reference only to abstractions
history
is concrete history fills in the blanks
with world events and real people things
that actually happened and we can test
out our principles by seeing how they
operate in history
[Music]
good history will be an accurate picture
of what happened in the past
with a sympathy for the people so that
one can learn from them
it gives us a fixity that is made up of
things that at the time
were constantly shifting and hard to
estimate
it is possible of course of landing a
man on the moon and returning safely to
the earth
i think u.s history is a really
extraordinary moment
in the history of the world
the story of this country is one of the
most interesting exciting compelling
stories that you could tell about human
life on this planet
returning to our history and seeing why
things happened the way they did can
give us some insight that we might not
otherwise have world war the study of
history expands you
you learn to empathize
with
very different ways of living
in the past
i think that's fun
i put it up against anything
i'm wilford mcclay
professor of history and letters
this is our course in american history
and determination let's begin
you